muy French looking today hey guys it is
Tuesday here on it's Graces I'm gonna
talk back to you let's do it let's start
on Alice shooter new person to person to
person vulva that don't know what a new
person comments on my videos I praise
the crap on them and welcome in to the
its price family I don't know what's a
new person I don't know I just guess
like I do with everything else in my
life the only real thing I know is that
we're all gonna die someday great start
as shooter more like Alice tutors I come
to this idea before but I'll say it
again it's a restaurant idea for a chain
next to Hooters called Cooter's and the
girls just let their Cooter's out got a
really great super bra matching because
why not
are you dating are you brother sisters
hey brothers it's dating please go it
air be just ghostly doll parts duper
super snoopers and Jeff ghostly doll
farts more like okay I'm totally afraid
of ghosts but if a ghost showed up to my
house and they farted I think that's how
I'm gonna get over my fear of ghosts
it's just imagining a ghost farting at
me you asking my mom if she wants to
watch camp Takota shall we watch a movie
yeah what have you guys well we can
watch camp Takota if you want you
haven't seen that with those women
they're not going to be silly are they
no it's a proper film I don't want to
see if it's just them being silly no
it's an actual film it's a comedy with
romance and drama because if they're
gonna be silly I'm not fine we won't
watch it then do not buy your mom silly
string
let's get her some yarn not enough heart
big new person new person to person not
enough heart bag more like there's a lot
of heartbreak like so much that you
can't check out in the ten items or less
Lane I still really miss Stephanie
doesn't that a lot that that dot
Stephanie's in rehab sorry I just had a
whole brain train that led me to trying
to figure out how to make rehabilitators
coming soon maybe now let's go over to
Twitter boo-boo Oh wrong channels MS
malls new person who's new person miss
malls more like I'm sorry maze mom you
don't a spell I have to get up at 6:00
a.m. Thank You Gracie something for
keeping me up with YouTube all bloody
night yeah it's my fault it's my fault
it's my fault I held a gun to your head
and made you click to the next video
it's my fault thank you for watching
please don't ever stop means walk I'll
teach you
Pythagorean theorem more like
Pythagorean your rump
he had a great butt Pythagoras did
pretty goddess new person to person to
person tree got it's more like Shh good
thing I'm not religious
you just bring order great Celtics
guidebook I think it's the best decision
I've made as an adult so far that's not
that it is no other decision will be as
solid as this one so just say no to
marriage you know to children say no to
fulfilling career toys my ideas keep
reading that book buy it brothers Toys
for Tots give him that book yellow be
disappointed until they get older and
they realize like oh my god that woman
was trying to help me more like Ellen no
I said stop yeah subscribe to grace
Helbig but always buy extra pants
because you might pee your pants
laughing or it's just your period coming
I don't know there's a lot of stuff
going on in that tweet you're in suck a
dick you know it just suck up crooked
chubby dick
I got flu now it's gonna go to and
petting it unless it's on the other side
louis parker new person-to-person new
person louis parker i barely know her
one point for me my list for summer is
as follows one netflix to eat three
sleep for repeat five learn how to tell
us the interesting story thank you for
watching le kathleen to person to person
to person and ally kathleen more like
those are to girl names that you put
together I don't trust you unless you
are someone that I should trust and I
trust you I am torn what a paradox your
shirt is annoying me not because it's
Harry Styles but because I actually hate
shirts with faces on them I will never
wear anything that has a human face on
it I don't know why I don't know why
this annoys me so much and I wish it did
it
thank you siobhan said gray new person
to person to person the chiffon the
secretary more like are you a French
circus clown my two-year-old brother
really likes it when the comments pop up
on the screen he laughed so hard I can't
hear anything you say concern face Oh
life sucks
I'm not having children you just can't
control their joy and their pain and
it's just I don't I wish there's just so
remote control just be like you know
there you go that's never talking back
new today of that you enjoy your time
with me
in this dramatic light Lego that's
offered got their Airy or rewind little
bit well there you go that's all for
commenting Oh double rewind